christina anstead is taking some time
to heal yeah i mean there's just a lot
going on
earlier this month the hgtv star
announced on social media that she and
husband aunt anstead
were separating after two years of
marriage
and now a source tells e.t christina
hates to see the end of her second
marriage
but she knows that she must be true to
herself and christina ultimately feels
like she and aunt
aren't a good match it's been super fun
traveling
and just spending time together and
we're looking forward to welcoming
baby the couple is parents to
one-year-old son hudson
moving forward the source says christina
is going to take this time to heal
and spend time with her children and
focus on her show
she and and plan to co-parent their son
and remain
friends christina is also mom to
ten-year-old daughter taylor
and five-year-old son braden with her
ex-husband tarek el moussa
it's been great the kids are such
different ages but they get along so
well
christina and tariq are co-stars on the
hit home renovation show flip or flop
they filed for divorce in 2017 after
eight years of marriage
but continue to work together you ready
to pick up some trash
if dark thinks haven't cleaned up this
house he is sorely mistaken e.t
source says that after christina
antarek's divorce was finalized in 2018
christina never took the alone time to
find herself
christina and aunt married within months
of christina's divorce
our source says that friends had warned
christina about moving too fast with
aunt after her divorce
adding that she never had a moment to
take a breath
there's no big secret christina opened
up to e.t in december about how she was
managing her expanding family and career
you're an inspiration to a lot of
blended families which is more and more
prevalent these days what's your secret
to
making a blended family work are there
times where you have to step back and be
like this is really not what i want to
do but it's best for the kids
there is yeah of course okay yeah i
think any
divorce family deals with that kind of
stuff and sometimes you know things can
be difficult but
at the end of the day like the kids love
to see all of us together all the time
so that's that's what works
we ask this a lot of women in hollywood
but it's because we're looking for the
answer
yeah i want to know about balance oh no
like you do have a big career
and you have a lot of people depending
on you for that career and so
how do you choose when it's mom time and
when it's designer time and when it's tv
star time
and when it's you know i think i just
take it one day at a time i do try to
schedule out the week and
i do make sure that when i get home like
i'm done you know that's when my emails
can get really backed up
because i just like when i get home i
need to be totally present for the kids
like there's just way too much going on
so that's a big thing and then on the
weekend same thing just like make sure
that we're doing lots of family time
my kids love like little things like
board games they love swimming
so thank god for the pool and that keeps
them busy and distracted right
it's just it's just one day at a time